bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france difficile de s'y
retrouver dans ce dossier qu'elle serait
l'implication de joe biden dont les
affaires ukrainienne il est certain
qu'il est mêlé à la chose au moins sur
le fait qu'il a poussé le président
porochenko à l'époque l'ancien président
pour cenco à faire démissionner le
procureur général d'ukraine
shocking qui semble-t-il enquêter sur la
corruption dont le fils de joe biden
était soupçonné donc bien sûr qu'il y a
un lien entre bayonne et pau rosen
courra liens troubles qui n'a jamais été
totalement éclaircies dans la mesure où
effectivement le procureur shocking
avait été licencié aujourd'hui la faire
rebondir ce qui évidemment va changer de
président en ukraine et donc les choses
évoluent sur un jeu sous un jour
défavorable à l'ancien président
ukrainien prochaine comme et par le fait
même aussi sur byden le candidat aux
élections alors ya plusieurs
personnalités américaines qui sont plus
ou moins liés à cette affaire il ya bien
sûr pas eden père byden fils ilia obama
il ya kerry ya soros donc tous ces noms
circulent évidemment on voit bien que
c'est toute la nébuleuse de ce qu'on
appelle le type state où l'état profond
tout au moins les milieux liés au parti
démocrate américain qui sont visés par
cette affaire comme une espèce de contre
attaque de 30 qui lui même avait été
menacé d' impeachment pour avoir pointé
intervenu auprès du président jay lane
ski l'actuel président ukrainien pour
justement byetone et côté petro
porochenko alors qu'est ce qui lui est
reproché très précisément il lui
reprochait d'avoir de s'être soumis à
byden en échange d'un prêt que l'ukraine
que son gouvernement ait obtenu d'avoir
en quelque sorte annulé l'an qué
sur la corruption de raiden c'est à dire
du fils de baye dun nommé dans le
conseil d'administration de l'entreprise
gazière bourhis m'a juste après la
petite révolution de maidan dont on voit
de toute façon à quel point les états
unis les différents lobbys existants aux
états unis ont successivement sont
successivement intervenu dans les
affaires américaines dès 2014 et donc ça
fait ressortir à la fois les ingérences
américaines dans les affaires
ukrainienne les ingérences politiques
les les intérêts économiques que l'on a
eus suite pour les pour un certain
nombre de personnalités américaines en
particulier en l'occurrence pour rentrer
byden donc pour la famille par ibm qui a
profité en quelque sorte de des
changements politiques en ukraine pour
en quelque sorte obtenir des postes et
bien sûr de l'argent qui s'est retrouvée
qui se serait retrouvé dans les paradis
fiscaux de la famille paré d'honneur du
fils byden du fils de l'actuel candidat
aux élections américaines
alors le crâne est décidément au coeur
de l'élection présidentielle américaine
et quel peut être l'impact de cette
affaire dans la course à la maison
blanche est pour le moment si on ne veut
pas de nouveaux rebondissements on
pourrait supposer qu'il y aura d'autres
il est clair que la position de baden et
très fortement nous tous et puisque il
apparaît directement que ses ingérences
dans les affaires ukrainiennes étaient
liés à des intérêts familiaux à les
intérêts aux intérêts de son fils qu'il
avait été nommé qu'il aurait été nommé
dans l'entreprise gazier tourisme a et
on voit donc il y à des conflits
d'intérêts
l'intérieur de la classe politique
américaines qui sont liées à des
conflits d'intérêts qui existe dans la
classe politique ukrainienne donc on
sent qu'il y a tout se mélange d intérêt
privé et intérêt politique entre mêlée
depuis des deux au moins 2014 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
donald trump nord aurait tort si je puis
dire de se gêner de profiter de cette
situation même s'il lui aussi
effectivement joue sur le sur le sur la
scène ukrainienne pour renforcer sa
position lors des élections qui viennent
faire les élections de l'automne
prochain et alors justement vous
répondez à cette question mais comment
est ce que vous expliquez que de tels
enregistrements soient dévoilés
aujourd'hui précisément et est-ce qu'on
peut se fie aussi à ces fameux
enregistrements audio et à celui qui les
a révélés ce parlementaires ukrainiens
alors il n'est pas sûr que ces
enregistrements pour le moc pas affirmer
qu'ils sont authentiques
ils font partie de cette guerre
d'information qui a quand même permis de
révéler une chose c'est l'imbrication
des intérêts privés et étatiques entre
les états unis et l'ukraine et le degré
de corruption on le savait déjà mais le
degré de corruption en ukraine mais le
lien qui existe entre la corruption
ukrainienne et et les etats-unis ce qui
évidemment est quand même
particulièrement important toutes les
conséquences de tout ce qui sera révélé
de ce qui a commencé à être révélée
seront importantes aussi bien pour les
états unis que pour l'ukraine en quelque
sorte c'est une taie légitimation en
part par sienne au moins dû maidan qui
ont le doigt quand même de le rappeler a
été soutenue par les pays occidentaux et
en particulier par les états unis de
façon très active au nom de la
démocratisation et de la fin de la
corruption en ukraine alors qu'on a
évidemment exactement le contraire qui
se déroule sous nos yeux
merci beaucoup bruno drye enseignant
chercheur à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales